[Música]
economía en directo américa de france24
àngel hablando conmigo en el estudio
daniela una noticia que realmente es
preocupante sobre todo para nosotros los
habitantes en nuestros países de américa
latina y el caribe porque las tasas de
interés siguen subiendo así de raúl
usted se acuerda que durante los peores
momentos de la pandemia del cobi 19 la
mayoría de bancos centrales del mundo
decidió reducir precisamente al máximo
las tasas de interés pues ahora están en
la tónica contraria este movimiento de
bajar tasas impulsa el consumo y le da
ritmo a la economía pero un mayor
consumo llevado al extremo también puede
provocar aumento de precios y por eso
los bancos tienen que encontrar un
equilibrio esa es la tarea principal hoy
el escenario entonces es el contrario al
que había en la pandemia el consumo
desenfrenado y también las consecuencias
de la guerra en ucrania tienen los
precios por las nubes lo que impulsó a
los tomadores de decisiones de política
monetaria a comenzar a subir esas tasas
de interés el riesgo ahora es que un
menor crecimiento lleve a una recesión
pongamos ahora ni en contexto digamos
algunos ejemplos de países bueno américa
latina comenzó a subir tasas de interés
inclusive antes que eeuu el más reciente
de movimiento se vio en el banco central
de perú que las elevó el jueves al 6 por
ciento ahora vamos a ver el gráfico eso
no es un movimiento aislado raúl en el
gráfico comparamos cómo estaban las
tasas hace un año y cómo están ahora en
las principales de economías de la
región por ejemplo en perú se disparó
desde el 0 25 por ciento al 6 colombia
salto del 1 75 por ciento al 7.5 por
ciento en apenas un año en chile el alza
ha sido mayor todavía ya están 9 por
ciento y brasil y méxico- que hace un
año estaban en 4.25 hoy están mucho más
altas en brasil casi llega el 14 por
ciento ahora hay que hacer una
aclaración es que las tasas de
referencia por lo general son las que
usa el banco central para prestar dinero
a los bancos comerciales y estos
trasladan el incremento adivina que a
nosotros por supuesto en una mayor
proporción así es así que puede ser
mucho cuidado con créditos y también con
el uso en las tarjetas de crédito sobre
todo a pagar los consumos a larga muy
largo plazo
si porque termina pagando mucho los
créditos de vivienda también se vuelven
más caros vamos a argentina que la
situación pues no está bien que digamos
porque el cambio de ministro de economía
trajo incertidumbre económica es uno de
los peores países de la región materia
económica no van y la situación es
bastante crítica en argentina en ese
país los cambios de precios en las
etiquetas de los productos están así que
a la orden del día de esta manera
entonces los comerciantes tratan de
blindar sus ganancias de la devaluación
de la moneda local que se ha acentuado
después de los cambios en el ministerio
de economía hoy en día para los
consumidores entonces comprar es
sinónimo de ahorrar porque rafael nos
cuenta más
la crisis política tiene repercusiones
en la economía de los argentinos los
roces dentro de la coalición que
gobierna el país ponen más presión sobre
unos precios ya muy elevados amaneció
que todo el mundo puso carteles 20 por
ciento más del precio actual la crisis
escaló el pasado fin de semana con la
renuncia del ministro de economía martín
guzmán negociador en el recién aprobado
acuerdo de refinanciación de deuda con
el fmi y la salida del ministro disparó
el cambio del dólar en el mercado
informal lo que repercute en los precios
de los establecimientos que promediaron
en un 20 por ciento sus incrementos una
estrategia con la que buscan defenderse
ante la devaluación de la moneda local
un factor endémico en la nación
suramericana lo que no deja de preocupar
a muchos
espero que frenen pero que frenen porque
la verdad que es una locura no sabes
cómo manejar los precios no sabes con
cuanta plata van a hacer al mercado
cuanta marca adidas podéis comprar
aunque empresa la puedes vender
porque realmente no va a poder comprar
el gobierno de alberto fernández trabaja
además por saldar una deuda de unos 40
mil millones de dólares con el fondo
monetario internacional adquirida por
mauricio macri por detrás de venezuela
argentina es el país con más inflación
de las naciones suramericanas con un 67
por ciento anual sin embargo los mismos
comerciantes se reconocen que a pesar
del incremento de los precios las ventas
no se detienen el informe de rafael
pérez nuestro compañero de la reacción
en español aquí en frases de 4 dan y
vamos con otra noticia pues nada
alentadora mejor dicho es un viernes
pues oscuro y oscuro exactamente el
precio del dólar se acerca cada vez más
al euro hay ganadores y hay perdedores
sí señor como en todas las movidas
económicas hay ganadores y perdedores
por primera vez en dos décadas
estas dos monedas valen casi lo mismo
hoy en día un euro cuesta 10 16 dólares
cuando en la crisis de 2008 la moneda
europea llegó a costar 1,6 dólares así
que la brecha se ha ido reduciendo y eso
se da porque el dólar es considerado un
refugio para los esta tendencia entonces
amenaza con perjudicar a las empresas
estadounidenses o muchas de ellas porque
sus productos se vuelven más caros para
los compradores extranjeros y si las
exportaciones estadounidenses se
debilitan también lo hace la economía
pero también hay ganadores un dólar más
fuerte alivia un poco la inflación que
es la más alta en 40 años porque la gran
variedad de bienes que se importan desde
automóviles y computadores hasta
juguetes y equipos médicos se vuelven
menos costosos sin dejar de lado también
raúl que a los turistas estadounidenses
les convendrá mucho más ir a europa
económicamente hablando y a otros países
porque su moneda está fortalecida claro
pues dani muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información
económica nosotros nos vamos directo
hasta argentina para precisamente hablar
de este sacudón económico y político
tras la renuncia del ex ministro de
economía martín guzmán y con la llegada
de esta nueva ministra vamos a hablar
también con nuestro corresponsal en
buenos aires gracias al